how have you been single now i think
three years now
i think i'm too nice no i know and then
when i'm like nah i'm not gonna let
anybody walk alone for me
that's it i didn't see anybody ever
that's a wig
that's a wig okay why would you wear a
wig to uh
oh but then again i used to be like that
to be like i
always used to be like when i first
started my dress i was like oh yeah you
know you shouldn't have
uh texturizer or wigs and stuff like
that
and sometimes there's a reason why the
people got wigs when i got more into
here and stuff like that
people shouldn't should mind in business
and not ask why people have
what they have on their head because
there might be some [ __ ] like when
people ask me why
why are you diss hold and you don't have
kids and then i used to reply well
be my girl we can't have kids and it
felt super bad i'm like no no no no hold
that hell
it's not true but see how you feel you
should mind your business
so weird because um
i always like to say to people like
straight away
i don't have any hair i wear a wig
okay this is going to freak you came
over at the wrong time
i'm coughing for me [ __ ] because you
feel like you feel good about your guess
from what i know just say alopecia
i'ma say it oh wow
why do you wear a wig i've got an
alopecia
um so my hair just it just falls out
cop you're no longer a wizard i'm the
wizard now v
a wizard preacher yes yes i am
okay harry all right they're joining
hogwarts
let's go so what are you
slytherin come on come on you're smiling
look at me i'm awful it just suits you
but um yeah
this is probably like the weirdest day
you've ever been on
the best day i've been on i like it
it's unique oh yeah he's so sweet
yeah are you you're unique ah look at
you you big bear
i don't think i've ever been treated
right i do think that boys use me
because they think
i've got nothing else going with me you
know because they just think oh she's
got no here she can't get anybody else
people lie to me quite a lot i find it
really hard to trust
i like it oh good that's nice
yeah i think
[Music]
thank you thanks so much
are you going to see each other again
yeah i'd like to see you again
[Music]
for sure
i think romantically
i didn't feel like it was there for me
um
shut it off it's hard to watch time she
was answering she was like
getting away oh yeah because you had
this whole story about her like
being seen as unattractive because she's
bald that you know she never meets nice
guys and the moment she's kind to people
they run away
and here you have a guy who's like super
kind to her and she's just like
it's not working for me you're such a
nice guy
open warm kind of person so it's nice
it's refreshing
[Music]
while you push him away you push him
away
oh so i mean even his response was
wasn't wasn't the best you know i mean
the girl says no just walk away don't
question why
if a girl tells you i'm not interested
don't ask why
leave that's you because they're rarely
going to be able to tell you why
because sometimes they don't even know
themselves and so whatever answer you're
hoping to get is just going to confuse
you
walk away take your l uh i'm going to
take an altitude
and you take it you put it in a bag and
then you heat it up whenever you get
home and you get hungry yeah this broth
is goofy
that's funny but a lot of people like
that they're like i want this i want
this they get that they're like ugh
that's not what i want
and it's just funny to watch but it's
like this is such like a new redemption
arc and all that stuff and at the end of
it she's just like
she did to him what what dudes did to
her
but the thing that happened is like what
she want it's like the way she read
about things right and she answers the
question and when most people answer the
question it's like
oh i want spicy food all right cool
here's uh chicken bindalu
man that's that's not exactly what i
meant my
chick bye bye spicy i was more thinking
you know
so when they get what they ask for they
don't want it because it's too broad
it's too
there's other levels to this you know
chicken bin the loo is kind of you know
it's kind of out there so if we yeah
it's
not ready for that spice and she was not
ready for that kind of kindness
hmm she just wanted to shock the
[ __ ] and then she
it looked like she wanted to shock the
guy i'm gonna go here with a plan
i'ma shock him boom bop take my wig off
and didn't get the response that he you
know what i mean
he's like yeah sure i think people can
intellectually want something
but then what they want this release is
different you know
it's like it's like you ever seen people
who are like i want a good boyfriend but
then they just keep dating toxic dudes
it's like
whatever sometimes it's conditioning
sometimes it's trauma
sometimes it's just bad feedback loops
where you associate
love and affection with negative stimuli
you know
it's possible it's that or maybe it's
possible she just looked at this dude
he's like i'm not attracted to this guy
and then she said it's because of other
things
who knows i just thought it was
interesting that people talk about like
for me it's like really personality
first and i'm really personality
oriented and i need a really kind person
but then when you find time and time
again and what
kind dudes encounters that when they're
overly nice
women tend to curl away from that and
it's kind of like um
i think that when it comes to
niceness for quite a lot of people if
you are
too nice you are seen as weak yes
definitely of course
they it's like
it's like people like kind people with a
little bit of sense of danger
right so like if you look at like disney
characters
like uh like aladdin kind of person but
also a thief
beauty and the beast kind monster you
know
or you take the hunchback of notre dame
there you go it's basically a freak
monster
uh but also extremely kind those are the
archetypes of like how we've taught
young women to like look for in other
people right that bad boy
with a sock redeemable heart
there's always that redemption arc where
like the woman comes in and basically
saves the man from his demons and
turns him into a committed man who can
be dangerous when necessary
but is really kind it's that same trope
so
i see it all the time in dating it's
just like dudes with a little bit of a
troubled past
girls love to try to fix that and go for
that so um
it's just it's just interesting to see
those patterns this is not me meant to
be an educational
video or anything like that just like
peep game this thing is common
and just because they say they want
something doesn't mean that's all
they're looking for or that's the most
important thing
the thing that happened is that when
women they want they want
bad guys it's really just because a bad
guy
comes with qualities
they assert themselves more they
they take more decisions they when you
too kind and you don't want to take
space and
you just you know i'm gonna let you do
your thing and oh my god you're so nice
today and
i don't wanna disrupt you in this it's
it's it's
look like a pushover so part of this
video is not to tell her she has to date
this dude or needs to
point is when you say you want something
but you keep dating the opposite at some
point you have to question yourself
and what are you doing to attract that
and what are you doing to push away the
dudes that you claim you want
a lot of us play into our negative oh i
keep attracting [ __ ] boys
maybe there's something about you that
draws them to you or maybe there's
something about you that makes you keep
thinking that
right so just question yourself why do
you
draw these type of people or one type of
people or anything like that
that's what she claimed she claimed she
dropped kept drawing one type of woman
uh one type of man there's something to
say about that
so and it was just interesting to watch
that's all and it's really weird because
whenever people like i attract one
one type of people one type of people
and i'm like no you say
yes to one type of people that's right
you left
one type of people because you attract a
whole bunch of people
you end up what you end up with or
that's some different
at the end of the process what you end
up with so whenever you swipe in your
mind yes yes yes no yes yes no yes
what you end up with is what you
attracted you attracted a whole pool but
you said no to other people
yep so saying that the only thing that i
attract is
this it's not
genuine it's not real it's not true
yeah yeah so we want to hear your
thoughts what do you guys think about
the video that you saw and
some of the stuff that we said do you
agree or disagree we want to see your
comments in the links below
so check that out also we notice that
half of you 50
of you are still not subscribed say that
again it's a mistake
you're watching you're not hitting the
sub button but we're making the content
you're already watching
hit the sub button make our eagle feel
good the way we make your eyes feel good
might as well you know what i'm saying
reciprocity it's a feel-good feel-good
situation
what's that that was very reciprocity
you want to think about that
okay hit the button
check out our discord get that money
get the paperwork